[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous nous ne sommes pas à
saint tropez mais dans six ans par les
sports les missions qu'il ne faut pas
absolument pas manquer si vous êtes un
accro à l'actualité sportive du
département
malgré les températures estivales qui
nous donne envie de nous prélasser au
bord de la piscine nos chroniqueurs ont
une nouvelle fois envie de faire vivre
ce sport local en transpirant ils sont
quatre en plateau aujourd'hui
présentation en musique on commence à ma
droite elle est amatrice de pole dance
sport qui mêle danse et acrobatie autour
d'une barre une passion qui est devenue
son métier karl est aujourd'hui
performeuse et professeurs son sourire
va vous faire fondre notre ambassadrice
de charme
hélène de la grange est avec nous pour
cette émission pendant une heure bonjour
voila j'ai une petite question pour vous
et l'aisne
est ce qu'on arrive à faire du pole
dance pensée température c'est un peu
compliqué mais
parfois on peut faire des prises
incroyable parce qu'on colle vraiment
vraiment beaucoup
donc voilà faut bien s'hydrater voilà
faut s'hydrater
on fabrique oui oui c'est possible on
passe à notre deuxième chroniqueur
musique il a bravé la chaleur depuis
plaisir à pour participer à ce tournoi
c'est un cavalier international qui a
remporté de nombreux nombreux prix on le
surnomme sur ce plateau le zorro
illinois râble cauterets d'autres et qui
fait l'honneur de venir sur ce plateau
bonjour à vous bonjour michael bonjour à
tous j'ai l'impression de vous voir de
plus en plus bronzé au fur et à mesure
des tarifs j'ai un métier l'extérieur
donc je suis très exposé rassurez-nous
vous avez quand même un petit peu
travaillé les missions bien venir très
studieuse comme d'habitude comme
d'habitude on va voir ça dans quelques
instants
repasse à ma droite musique il est dans
le monde du rugby depuis sa plus tendre
enfance il a connu des matches sous la
pluie sous la halle et agissent sous de
fortes chaleurs
son expérience sera primordiale pour
gérer les débats caniculaire pendant
cette émission il va à n'en pas douter
fait remonter à la température mesdames
et messieurs je vous présente le coach
du rugby-club de plaisir jean miss
genlis bonjour michael bonjour à tous un
ça va ça ne vous fait pas peur les
fortes températures
il fait chaud quand même l'un fait chaud
comme cet opéra thurella moi j'ai la
barra qui glissent eux plutôt que le col
en forme pour ce début d'émission gens
me disent on va avoir un peu plus tard
dans l'émission si houlette autant on
termine par l'un des plus grands
tacticiens des yvelines musique sa
spécialité le football américain
les directeurs sportifs chez les
templiers d'elancourt mais il est
également expert dans le sport local
je sais qu'il va mettre le feu sur ce
bateau pendant cette émission freiner
avec anderson est avec nous bonjour je
leur ai dit bonjour à tout le monde
c'est un plaisir de vous revoir cette
émission aura toujours mais ça fait
toujours plaisir de venir et discuter
avec tout le monde
alors vous qui êtes coach sportif par là
il faut s'hydrater cependant c'est
important
c'est compliqué le sport préféré les
températures du matin ou du soir quand
il fait un peu moins chaud mais dans ce
temps là c'est compliqué voilà vous avez
tous un petit verre d'eau au cas où et
quand même pendant cette émission et
n'hésitez pas si c'est bien de lower
demande n'hésitez pas à lui passé alors
avant de vous présenter les thèmes de
l'émission j'aimerais qu'on parle des
championnats de france universitaires
d'équitation la compétition est
organisée pendant trois jours au centre
équestre de versailles 46 car ils sont
venus de toutes les facs françaises pour
participer à l'événement au programme du
saut et du dressage les passages se font
devant jury petite particularité de ce
concours les cavaliers nous ont pas en
compétition avec leurs chevaux
explications au micro de mélinda correia
pour garantir l'équité
les chevaux sont tirés au sort donc
c'est au comité d'organisation de
fournir les chevaux donc ils n'étaient
pas tous sur place on a dû ont loué
aussi à des propriétaires mais une
grande partie vient du centre équestre
de versailles et du centre équestre
universitaire dorcel c'est intéressant
parce que du coup c'est aussi on n'a que
cinq minutes pour connaître le cheval
ils sont du temps tu parais des
cavaliers du club
avant on y prenons mettrait on a cinq
minutes dessus pour connaître et trouver
les votants et c'est super intéressant
raul vous qui êtes notre expert
équitation qu'est ce qu'on pensait de
cette compétition universitaire il n'est
pas encore parfaitement parfaitement
conçu j'ai jamais eu l'occasion
d'entraîner des étudiants pour ce
championnat mais par contre j'ai déjà
prêté des chevaux pour au comité pour
kippour pour fournir quoi pas cette
année à versailles non pas du tout mais
dans des années antérieures
ce qu'il ya c'est que c'est c'est pas
alors le fait de monter les chevaux
comme on dit au pied levé d'entre dans
notre jargon équestre sadc effectivement
sa mêlée les étudiants sur un un petit
pied d'égalité
après je pense qu'il serait intéressant
de mettre en place des différentes
catégories
parce que parfois on est un étudiant qui
peut être
niveau professionnel ou amateur et
d'autres juste pratiquants de loisirs
dont il ya des différences dans les
niveaux et je pense que ça manque de
d'équité à ce niveau là voilà c'est
intelligent genlis peut-être de tester
une monture finalement qu'on ne connaît
pas avant la compétition
est-ce que ce que je regardais le le
reportage là et ce n'est pas évident
parce que cinq minutes le connaissance
juste avant de pouvoir la montée c'est
pas c'est pas tous les jours quoi donc
c'est pas évident quand ça c'est sûr
eric vous êtes du même avis que j'en vis
vu faire un mois je trouve ça surprend
fin je trouve ça bien qu s'est passé pas
un sport auquel on peut penser en sport
universitaire autant des sports plus
accessibles comme le rugby un ballon une
prairie et c'est parti kwa trouve le
foot aussi
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut pas pour
l'équitation il faut trouver des chevaux
c'est vrai que c'est un investissement
c'est bien qu'ils aient des structures
qui permettent aux étudiants de de
prendre part à ce jeu à ce genre de
compétition comme ça je trouve que c'est
une bonne chose
après c'est sûr que comme ces îles ont
pas accès aux chevaux tout le temps
c'est vrai que ce challenge de monter
des chevaux qu'on ne connaît pas ça
rajoute à la difficulté de l'épreuve
donc c'est ça peut être ça peut être
aussi intéressant ça permet peut-être
plus d'équité
du coup entre les concurrents peut-être
je connais pas je me connecte au tirage
au sort ça dépend aussi du cheval qu'on
a finalement à peut-être qu'on salem en
plus aussi en exergue les cadets qualité
du cavalier plutôt que de la monture en
elle-même c'est un peu comme on garde
aussi en formule 1 parfois c'est la
meilleure voiture qui remporte pas
forcément en fonction du talent du
pilote
la balle a comme on n'est pas au courant
de la monture qu'on va avoir c'est
vraiment vraiment le talent du sportif
qui va faire la différence je pense ça
pourrait adopter de grosses compétitions
peut-être hélène jouzeau rapide et les
compétitions de ce type
je ne sais pas si on pourra aller jusque
là mon avis c'est déjà bien de
de faire des petites compétitions comme
ça peut-être régionales ou même
nationale je sais pas si ça se fait
à l'étranger d'ailleurs je sais pas ce
qu'est notre expert et venturi a déjà
c'est faisable mais moi je ne sais pas
si c'est si cette pratique de jean luc
herzog
pour moi c'est plus une compétition qui
fon compétition mais une compétition qui
met en avant les capacités du gouët du
cavalier
et pas le binôme avec le cheval
après de là à le faire ou jeux
olympiques en compétition internationale
c'est pas du tout ah oui c'est possible
ou pas dans une grande compétition de
mettre ce type de formule en place je ne
sais pas si ça serait si intéressante ça
allait aller toucher le haut niveau avec
des
je pense que là le but il est vraiment
de confronter des étudiants autour de
sport donc aller vraiment intégrer ça
dans des dents des événements sportifs
de cette taille je crois pas que c'est
son jeu vous pas de route et que soi
même
non ce n est pas favorable non pas du
tout alors on va passer maintenant au
programme de l'émission aujourd'hui nous
allons parler de voile et de tanguy de
lamotte le versailles va arrêter la
compétition après la transat jacques
vabre nous reviendrons également sur
l'open de france de golf la compétition
programmée du 29 juin au 2 juillet mais
avant de développer ces thèmes coup de
projecteur sur le parcours de plaisir en
fédérale 3 de rugby
plaisir n'ira pas en demi finale du
championnat de france de fédérale 3 les
hommes de jean miss qui est en plateau
ici se sont inclinés contre tours sur
terrain neutre à nogent leur trou après
avoir accroché leurs adversaires 9 à 12
pendant une grande partie du match les
plaisirs ont craqué dans les dix
dernières minutes pour finalement
s'incliner à 24 à 9 malgré cette défaite
plaisir à réaliser le meilleur parcours
de son histoire dans cette division
évoluera la saison prochaine dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 la question
sur ce thème qui vous intéressent
forcément j'en lis le parcours de
plaisir at il marqué l'histoire du club
vous votez oui ou non est-ce que ça
marque l'histoire du club
ce parcours oui oui vous êtes unanimes
là-dessus
raoult je vous ai senti un petit peu
hésitant pourquoi j'attends déjà
désengagé un petit peu la vie de la
vidéo on lui demandera juste après du
prénom mais bon je pense que c'est assez
des objectifs qu'ils ont et qui ont pas
été atteint depuis quelques années déjà
je ce résultat-là donc forcément une
fois que pour qu'on repasse dans une
division supérieure et que ça faisait
plusieurs années pour l'attendre ccc des
dates qui marquent et on va se souvenir
forcément à l'échelle d'un club d'un
club national passe forcément ça marque
les esprits donc ça rentre dans
l'histoire par définition jamais oui je
dirai oui oui bien sûr que ça va entrer
dans l'histoire du club puisque c'est la
plus belle saison de l'histoire du club
à la mesure où les deux équipes
respectivement la réserve a fait demi
finaliste du championnat de france et
l'équipe première quart de finaliste
donc c'est la meilleure saison de
l'histoire du club donc ça restera ça
restera bien sûr
dans cette histoire maintenant là où je
veux un petit bémol c'est ce qui reste
vraiment dans l'histoire des clubs ce
sont les titres
une saison c'est bien on y fera
référence à cette saison certainement
c'est la deuxième fois effectivement que
le club franchi la marche de la fédérale
2 la première fois elle y était resté
qu'une seule saison donc voir maintenant
essayer de c'était il ya trois ans
c'était il ya trois ans voilà tout à
fait juste juste avant que j'arrive et
là maintenant j'espère que le club sera
prendre en compte les erreurs
éventuelles qui a été fait il ya trois
saisons et qui n'ont pas permis au club
de rester à ce niveau là et même si
c'est vendu d'un tout petit cheveu qui
sont qui sont redescendus et sur le
dernier match sobre seulement mais il y
aura quand même
il y aura quand même des enseignements à
tirer mais c'est vrai que je peux vous
dire c'est que cette saison
effectivement c'est la plus belle mais
moi pour ce qui reste un club esquisse
qui marque à jamais un club c'est un
titre il aurait fallu que vous gagnez le
champion de france mais voilà si vous
êtes champion de france sas a marqué
l'histoire d'un club parce que ça reste
c'est un grand dans le club
et vous avez vu contre tours qui crie
finalement final tout est allé très
content périgueux oui tout à fait tour
est à venir est votre pire est que pour
moi périgueux qui est une équipe qui a
été relégué de fédérale une
administrativement et financièrement et
à garder son effectif pour moi c'est le
grand vainqueur
du début de saison et qui trouve un peu
le championnat mais ça c'est un autre
débat mais tour et en finale donc on ne
peut que être grandi par cette défaite
face à cette équipe
surtout qu effectivement le score 24 nov
vous l'avez dit très très bien dit ne
reflète pas du tout le reflet du match
et en fait en effet sa rigueur et lui
c'est sûr sur la manière par contre
l'idée mérite pas du tout en fait ils
ont produit plus de jeu que nous sur la
rencontre
est ce que les supporters fera la
conversion vont en parler encore pendant
des années des années j'en lis le disait
il n'ya pas de titre au bout est ce
qu'on va quand même en parler pendant
des années des années des années des
années avec 300 signalements il était en
fédérale 2 on en parle encore
aujourd'hui autour de cette table nombre
au final il ya bon bien sûr ce qui
marche c'est les titres mais de façon
après c'est aussi on par rapport au
mieux que le club ait pu faire donc
c'est vrai que par rapport à ce qui a
été fait par le passé ça ça devient la
nouvelle référence et je pense que de ce
point de vue là jusqu'à ce qu'ils
arrivent à faire mieux que ce qui a été
fait cette année ça restera ça sera
discuté parmi les supporters et ça
laissera des bons souvenirs et je pense
que si c'est au delà des titres qui
reste objectivement ce qui est risqué
dans la vitrine des trophées
ça reste quand même des souvenirs une
aventure humaine que qui ne s'efface pas
et c'est vrai que les joueurs
continueront à jouer et qui auront
l'opportunité de partager ce savoir avec
ceux vécus avec les nouveaux joueurs ça
permet aussi de me faire perpétuer le le
bas tout ce qui a été vécu cette année
tout ce qui a été tout ce qui a été
réalisé donc je pense que c'est en ça
marquera sa marque aura peut-être pas
autant qu'on aurait aimé parce qu'on
aime toujours aller le plus loin
possible
il faut pas oublier que plus on avance
dans la compétition plus c'est compliqué
le niveau le niveau 6 au niveau national
et il n'y a qu'un seul champion trouva
là il n'a jamais qu'un seul et à quel
moment on sait laine que qu'on a réalisé
à l'export l'a finalement
le club arrive arrive en quarts de
finale est ce que c'est un exploit a
calmement je pense qu'on sait en
fonction de la difficulté qu'on a eu à
surmonter et de ce qu'on a et de la
pente qu'on a remonté aussi là
évidemment ils ont déjà eu ce résultat
il ya quelques années il le il
là ils recommencent là cette saison là
ils savent que ça a été difficile
maintenant je pense que
et ça sera par rapport aux supporters
très tôt aux yeux des supporters
on sait qui est un exploit ou pas le
retentissement dans une ville oui oui
évidemment mais je pense que et en inde
et qui réitère l'exploit là ils vont
être attendus aussi à faire autre chose
à faire mieux aussi
donc je pense qu'ils vont être
supportées ils vont être voilà à du lait
etc
mais avec l'espoir que y est maintenant
quelque chose de plus grand dernière
plaisir sera attendu au tournant
jean-mi sa saison prochaine pas ses
supporters au tournant non je pense que
j'irai pas au tournant parce que là le
club a franchi le march fédérale 2 donc
on va se retrouver le club va se
retrouver quand même on va dire un petit
peu petit chez les grandes voix alors
que là on était grande chez les petits
donc là de les matchs vont pas être les
mêmes
on va faire je pense pas que le club et
je suis ce que je peux souhaiter au club
mais je ne pense pas que le club
face les premières dates affichent dès
la première saison en fédérale 2 donc ça
va être plus compliqué plus difficile
je pense que les spectateurs pour pour
les ceux qui s'y connaissent un peu et
ils vont et ils vont bien le comprendre
on peut pas faire les deux même saison
alors qu'on a changé de niveau c'est pas
possible
quel est votre plus beau souvenir de
cette épopée
mon plus beau souvenir à mon plus beau
souvenir c'est le match de la montée je
pense c'est le match de la montée
voilà parce qu'obtenir une montée c'est
compliqué donc le match contre cergy ça
ou non le match de la montée
moi j'ai remonté c'était à markhamat
aller sur agissent et un huitième donc
c'était le match retour à marcq en
baroeul où malgré le fait qu'on ait
perdu ce sur ce match là mais sur
l'ensemble des deux matches
on monte et je pense que c'est tellement
difficile la montée que c'est vraiment
ce qui marque le plus
surtout qu'ensuite pour moi les phases
finales s'appartient plus aux joueurs
qu'au dirigeant et co entraîneur donc
les phases finales c'est de la cerise
sur le gâteau pour les joueurs c'est là
que le groupe se fait c'est là que on
vit les plus belles choses mais ça
appartiennent plus aux joueurs qu'aux
autres est ce que j'ai un message à
faire passer à vos joueurs
si vous regarde en ce moment bach qui je
trouve est ensuite merci beaucoup
janvier alors après cette page résultat
on passe à notre coup de projecteur
jingle
[Musique]
dans notre coup de projecteur du
baseball direction montigny le
bretonneux l'équipe senior des cougars a
effectué cet été un gros recrutement
pour viser le haut du classement de
première division
parmi les recrues une certaine mélissa
marion une joueuse formé au club et qui
est devenu en 2015 la première femme de
l'histoire à intégrer l'européenne
lycans dirigé par la lm mlb l'équivalent
de la première division américaine de
baseball
aujourd'hui âgée de 18 ans et après un
passage à montpellier elle revient pour
aider les cougars remporter le titre
mais elle ne devrait pas rester plus
d'une saison
on les gouttes là j'ai des propositions
pour partir aux états-unis en sauf par
contre ces projets avec les filles dans
des universités des collèges bien
falloir que je fasse des choix dans pas
longtemps puisque c'est bientôt la
rentrée en septembre
bref c'était de pouvoir courir une
équipe professionnelle les deux de jouer
avec les pros
après je suis encore loin du niveau on
va dire et
je pense que pour moi c'est d'intégrer
un collège et après on va dire qu'aux
états unis tout est possible alors on
verra où ça me mènera
vous l'avez entendu la jeunesse devrait
donc partir aux usa si elle arrive à
valider son bac cette année elle devrait
intégrer une université américaine mais
pas en baseball mais en softball
l'équivalent du baseball chez les filles
la question sur ce thème fait-elle le
bon choix en partant aux états unis est
ce qu'elle fait le bon choix
oui vous êtes une alim falaq anderson
vous qui êtes spécialiste du sport us
on sait tous que le sport de haut niveau
c'est un milieu cruel et qu'on n'est
jamais qu'à une blessure de la retraite
donc c'est vrai que faire le choix des
études là si elle arrive à avoir son bac
elle déco elle décroche une bourse
sportive pour allait l'étudier aux états
unis est là là là elle a quatre ou cinq
ans de d'éligibilité au niveau
universitaire puisque c'est un niveau
amateur
donc il ya des règles particulier un
règlement très strict au niveau
universitaire américain et c'est vrai
qu'avec une bourse elle a 5 ans d'études
elle peut aller jusqu'à un acheteur on
sait que la basse et c'est pas gratuit
de l'éducation ça coûte ça coûte très
très cher et c'est vrai que c'est une
opportunité en or de ba de pouvoir
intégrer des gros programmes
universitaires là bas des grandes
universités aix prestigieuse non pas
uniquement sur le terrain mais aussi au
niveau académique et je pense que c'est
une opportunité à ne pas rater
et au niveau sportif au niveau sportif
passé forcément le plus haut niveau qui
peut y avoir pour des pour des femmes
après c'est vrai que ce serait pour du
softball ce serait pas du baseball parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le baseball est réservé
aux hommes aux états unis et c'est le
softball pour pour les femmes
après avoir si si ça lui convient est ce
qu'elle sera capable si par la suite
elle veut intégrer les professionnels de
rebasculer du softball au baseball
ça ça dépend aussi de la ligue de la
ligue de baseball parce que ils ont ils
ont des critères d'inclusion et de
recrutement qui sont pas forcément en sa
faveur ça peut être compliqué de
rivaliser avec des hommes qui ont dansé
le plus grand plus fort et sur un sport
où on se retrouve avec la crème de la
femme il faut pas obliger vous oubliez
que quand on passe en universitaire et
qu'on arrive au niveau professionnel
on est dans le 1 % du 1% du 1 % il ya
vraiment même des américains n'y arrive
pas aucune femme aujourd'hui en mlb
c'est dire que non seulement les pats
américaine pour aller jouer dans le jeu
américain en plus c'est une étrangère
qui veut faire ce que les amériques ont
jamais réussi à faire donc c'est passé
un gros défi nissent un beau défi on va
voir si elle a la carrure pour aller
jusqu'au bout et c'est tout ce que je
lui souhaite
peut-être qu'après elle aimerait le
baseball est peut-être que le softball
là bas au niveau où elles valent
pratique et ça c'est très bien de dire
oui elle est passionnée peut-être que
finalement ça lui plaira et que même si
elle passera en baseball mais ça l'a
croisée née dans le softball alors que
on lui a plus ou moins fait comprendre
qu'elle pouvait un jour peut-être aller
vers le baseball avec les garçons ouais
après elle peut peut-être tentés aux
états unis mais si c'est compliqué
peut-être qu'elle changera de pays où je
sais pas comment ça se passe les
mutations comme ça entre autres pays
parce qu'il ya d'autres nations qui sont
qu' on est très haut niveau en baseball
un principal pourrait revenir sur dans
un autre championnat japonais par
exemple qui vont de toute façon même si
elle réussit pas en baisse bout de là
bas je pense que si elle revient en
france avec le curseur ce cas là le
talon qu'elle aura et l'expérience
qu'elle aura acquise
je pense qu'elle sera est là elle aura
deux magnifiques chants cc 1
alors jean miss si elle part du groupe
au pour les états unis ce sera
finalement une bonne joueuse parmi les
très bonnes joueuses ou les bonnes
choses là bas aux états unis qui ont
l'habitude de jouer soft ball
finalement s'il reste ici à mon team
retenue ou en france ça pourrait devenir
une star est ce que justement il faut
faire se prendre ce risque d'aller aux
états unis d'être un peu plus dans
l'anonymat plutôt que d'être une star
ici en france et déjà être une star je
suis pas sûr qu'elle puisse devenir une
star des pays où le baseball ou le sous
le symbole blx baseball en parler en
tout cas oui ça m'a pas parlé mais c'est
qu'un grand média je pense que c'est
tout à fait naturel
siervo états unis c'est là le plus de
chances d'éclater
sportivement quoi parce que ici elle a
quand même fait mon sens c'est là qu'un
peu de chances de devenir une star
j'avais très jeune en être très jeune 18
ans et à 16 ans à peu près qu'on parlait
d'elle pour intégrer la mlb aux états
unis ouais mais bon après après tout ce
qu on dit en france l'afrique
l'a très bien démontré je ne savais pas
lui c'est le spécialiste de la
discipline
mais quatre mois que ça jamais été
réalisé par une par une américaine alors
moi je veux bien mais sur les coûts tout
ce que disent les journalistes sportifs
en france il ya beaucoup de déception
donc là à césar en la voyait déjà
intégré une équipe aux états unis bon
c'est si ça s'est jamais fait c'est pas
la route est longue
la route est très longue maintenant
forcément c'est là bas c'est là bas
qu'elle peut éventuellement il y arriver
ça c'est sûr s'il reste ici pour moi
mais je pense que c'est plus heureux
c'est plus heureux c'était pas un coup
marketing peut-être raul de là
lui laisser espérer six jeunes de
pouvoir intégrer le baseball aux états
unis non je pensais bien entendu parler
vraiment dans le monde entier bien sûr
parce que moi je me souviens en avoir
parlé quand on avait la première fois
qu'on a parlé des cougars une première
émission qui a presque un an on parlait
déjà son départ à mélissa maillot et
donc à l'époque elle d'avoir déjà 16 ans
puisque lé elle tout juste bachelière
pas encore par exemple au mitan qua non
ouais elle avait 16 ans un coup
marketing non bombe un jeu comme comme
tous les comme tous les athlètes qui
sortent un peu du lot on les détecte
très tôt donc toute façon je pense
qu'elle est décidée à le faire
maintenant elle est très jeune donc je
crois qu'il ya aucun point qui négatif à
ce départ l'aérien qui pourrait faire on
lui conseille de rester si elle devient
pas une star là-bas vue là jusque là là
tout le temps de redevenir une ici de
profiter de l'expertisé qu'elle va dont
elle va bénéficier là bas donc moi je
pense que c'est peu importe ce qui se
passe là bas ça va être forcément
positif pour la suite
de toute façon je de toute façon je
pense que sont son objectif c'est pas
d'être une star d'être hyper connu ce je
pense que c'est pas salé tellement
passionné que ce qu'elle veut c'est
jouer beaucoup avec les plus grands à
prendre voilà faire des matches qu'elle
n'aurait peut-être jamais pu faire s'il
était resté en national en france c'est
ça qu'elle qu'après évidemment sénat une
carrière
en softball hockey et dans le baseball
ça serait merveilleux
ça sera du pu semer mais effectivement
par rapport au marketing je pense que
c'est un très bon coup de pub pour le
club par contre est-ce qu'il ya pas plus
de mérite avec anderson à réussir dans
son club à permettre aux cougars de mon
team moto de remporter le championnat de
première division
plutôt que de partir là bas aux états
unis parce qu'elle ne terminera sûrement
pas la saison ici en france en baisse et
comme disait jean mistou finale c'est
être un requin dans un petit aquarium je
veux dire c'est pas sportivement il n'y
a pas le même challenge et et
l'opportunité de pouvoir remporter un
titre universitaire aux états unis c'est
quand même un niveau au dessus et il
faut pas oublier enfin on pas beaucoup
de jouer chez les professionnels etc
mais faut pas oublier que c'est 1,5
milieu très très cruel très rude parce
que ce qui va se passer c'est qu'elle va
faire ses années de softball à
l'université là bas on peut lui
souhaiter d'avoir d'avoir tous ses
diplômes comme ça quand elle va sortir
l'université au moins elle aura quelque
chose sur lequel retombée parce qu'après
ce qui va se passer c'est qu'elle risque
d'être drafté par une par une franchise
mlb et puis elle va pas elle va rentrer
dans le système des partis mme c'est des
ligues mineures américaines
et c'est vrai que c'est un quotidien
difficile avec eux une toute petite paye
beaucoup de voyages on n'est jamais chez
soi et quand on voit les histoires de
deux joueurs de baseball américain qui
passent leur vie en ligue mineure dans
l'espoir de pouvoir accéder à la grande
digue
c'est c'est compliqué c'est difficile
pour n'importe qui après la d2 chalenge
en plus parce que c'est pas un homme et
puis ça jamais été fait et la rave
c'est un leurre c'est un rêve oui après
son objectif aussi et puis ciel se donne
les moyens
tu sais moi je n'ai pas de boule de
cristal je peux lui souhaiter que
quelqu'un réussisse en dise et jouer à
l'extérieur
après il ya toujours de fortes
possibilités essayer de jouer à
d'intégrer les équipes nationales en
softball peut-être vers les jeux
olympiques
maintenant que le baseball et softball
sont revenus aux états du commun au jeu
avec tokyo parce que comme on disait les
japonais il joue joue beaucoup au
baseball imprime du japon c'est que
c'est des hommes qui jouent au baseball
les professionnels il ya aucune femme
non plus là bas faudrait regarder aussi
comment ça se passe à cuba et c'est et à
porto rico et ses autres championnats
aussi con qui produisent des gros
joueurs de baseball est ce qu'il ya une
opportunité aussi là-bas de poursuivre
il ya beaucoup de possibilités mais tous
les chemins sont avec une pente comme ça
quand il faut ça va être compliqué mais
lac de l'espoir et du travail
rien est impossible alors on lui
souhaite évidemment bon courage pour la
suite de sa carrière surtout de terminer
en trombe la saison avec les cougars
montigny-le-bretonneux
on passe maintenant hôtels suivants
c'est notre rubrique focus
aujourd'hui notre focus concerne le
monde de la voile de versailles et
tanguy de lamotte qui a participé au
dernier vendée globe va mettre entre
parenthèses la compétition grand large
juste après la transat jacques vabre
programmée en novembre prochain
le sportif de 39 ans va passer la barre
du projet initiative coeur à la
navigatrice samantha davies nous avons
réussi à joindre par téléphone tanguy de
lamotte pour qu'il nous explique son
choix
moi j'avais envie de faire autre chose
donc je vais partir à vivre à san
francisco avec ma femme et nos deux
garçons on a un petit garçon qu'il n'ya
pas très longtemps donc donc voilà c'est
2 c'est un tournant dans la vie
et puis c'est un une relance au niveau
professionnel donc vous avez
probablement le rdd métier que j'ai
exercé aux états unis ça sera le métier
d'architecte naval pour lequel je suis
diplômé et c'est la raison pour laquelle
je suis arrivé à la course au large
donc j'ai envie d'exercer ce métier là
donc c'est donc une décision personnelle
qui a poussé tanguy la mode saas éloigné
de la compétition au grand large la
question sur ce thème comprenez vous son
choix est ce que vous comprenez son
choix oui non d'arrêter cij à l'impasse
qui l'a 39 ans je vous précise n'ont
toujours pas vous êtes tous unanimes
genlis pourquoi vous qui êtes un fan de
voile allez-y c'est un fait de voile oui
oui moi y'a qu'à moi j'en ai fait
j'allais traverser mais bon c'est pas la
même chose mais je pense que c'est un
sport qui demande tellement de
d'abnégation et tellement de sacrifices
je parle d'après ce qu'on a entendu ce
qu'ils voulaient quand même mettre en
avant plus son côté famille maintenant
le son côté sportif il vient d'avoir un
enfant et deux enfants
du coup il y en avant dernier nadal
peut-être que le premier n'a peut-être
aussi regretté
certaines choses qu'il a loupé et
peut-être qu'il veut pas regretter avec
le deuxième et qui veut vivre vraiment
son côté familial à fond et laisser le
côté sportif un petit peu il a quand
même vécu de très belles choses
c'est qu'un aussi un métier qui est
assez assez dangereux donc je crois que
c'est un choix et on ne peut que
respecter le choix lorsqu'il est fait
comme ça de façon façon de famille al
saoud d'accord avec jean me suis tout à
fait d'accord avec avec jean
et d'autant plus que je remarque aussi
un petit point commun avec ma profession
lançait dans ces sports qui sont aussi
des sports métier c'est à dire qu'on est
obligé de vivre dedans pour pour être au
niveau ici est vraiment consacré à la
voile ce soit par le biais de son cursus
puisqu'ils ses études se sont consacrés
à sa sa profession aussi puisqu'il a été
à accastilleurs ensuite tout c'est tout
c'est traverser toutes ces régates
je le sais d'autant plus qu'une partie
de ma famille la fréquentait à l'époque
quand il vivait en normandie à deauville
donc c'est qu'il est il est justement en
train de se rendre compte de ne pas
qu'il ne faut surtout pas passer de
l'autre côté de la barre à ne pas d'un
seul coup de gâcher sa vie et se mettre
en marge de ce qu'est la vie en général
à côté du sport et à côté de sa passion
donc ce choix il est très intelligent et
il a la chance de le faire justement à
un âge pas trop avancé non plus parce
qu'il ya plein de gens il est quand même
assez jeune il a 39 ans avec soin par
exemple le deuxième du vendée globe du
dernier vendée globe
à 43 ans alors que l'âge à la force de
l'âge de 39 ans pour moi c'est pas jeune
mais mais c'est plus pas vieux mais en
tous les cas 39 ans il est déjà l'heure
pour se consacrer quand même à sa
famille
élever ses enfants et ses faux pas se
réveiller à 50 ans quand on a des
enfants
voilà je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
ne faut pas attendre la 50e la
soixantaine pour se rendre compte que
les enfants qu'il faudrait s'y consacrer
un petit peu donc non je pense que c'est
un choix tout à fait justifiable et je
pense que chez tous les sportifs de haut
niveau il est il est impératif de se
rendre compte de ça ce n'est pas dommage
fredec anderson du cou qui s'arrête si
jeune finalement il n'a pas gagné de
trophées majeurs et la voilà il a il a
toujours terminé termine 7ème de la
route du rhum en 2014 dixième du
septième vendée globe huitième de la
transat jacques vabre finalement ils
s'arrêtent jeune il avait encore 10 11
ans peut-être de voile devant lui au
grand large et
et justement il aurait peut-être pu
avoir cette possibilité de remporter des
trophées majeurs
oui peut-être ou peut-être pas on
discute comme s'il aurait pu mais il
aurait pu ne pas les pins il pourrait
non plus ne rien atteindre et regretté
justement de ne pas avoir consacré plus
de temps à sa famille on a fait
tellement démission avec avec sur la
voile etc et on l'a dit plusieurs fois
c'est psychologiquement c'est tellement
compliqué que si déjà il est plus motivé
de danser plus dangereux qu'autre chose
sylla et s'il a pu la tête à ça autant
autant qu'il fasse une pause peut-être
que ça lui sera bénéfique
et puis ces enfants vont grandir et puis
quand ils seront un peu plus grande peut
être qu'ils voudraient retourner à la
voile et puis montrer à ses enfants
partager cette passion avec le est
justement le fait qu'ils soient qu'ils
soient jeunes ça lui donne aussi
l'opportunité de faire une pause et plus
de reprendre plus tard sans être
complètement largués et je pense que ça
se comprend ça justifie et je vois pas
qui pourrait lui reprocher d'avoir
arrêté pour sa famille d'accord oui et
puis je pense que s'il le fait
maintenant c'est que il sent que ça peut
se faire maintenant s'ils l'avaient
pressenti une une course avec un
résultat potentiellement intéressants
dans peut-être les uns en deux ans
peut-être qu'il n'aurait pas arrêté tout
de suite tout de suite et là je pense
qu'ils avaient racheté en fait le
dernier bateau de jérémie beyou qui
avait terminé 3e du dernier vendée globe
donc voilà qui avait bouclé le tour du
monde dans 78 jours il y avait des
projets sportifs quand même derrière
oui mais on y pense équitable dans un
trio de tête d'une grande compétition
oui mais après vont avoir le bateau qui
va bien et sait mais c'est billy théorie
comme comme ils disent et c'est une
question de motivation je pense qu'ils
se sentaient peut-être trop loin d'eux
la motivation qu'il fallait pour avoir
tel résultat ou pétanque à un trio de
tête c'est moi s'il le fait maintenant
c'est qu'il sent que ses 20 ans et le
fait d'abandonner peut-être genlis la
compétition en novembre dernier le
dernier vendée globe il a terminé très
vite la compétition il a eu des
problèmes au niveau de son mât est ce
que ça a pu jouer peut-être sur son
sursaut
je sais pas sur sa performance du coup
son l'idée de rester au plus haut niveau
pendant de nombreuses années
est-ce que ça a cassé son moral tout
simplement cantonade et drôle sur le mât
cassé les performances futures
c'est indéniable maintenant
maintenant comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est un sport qui est cammas est
dangereux il s'est peut-être fait un
petit peu peur on ne sais pas peut-être
qu'il ne l'a pas dit où on lui a pas
posé la question
il s'est peut-être rendu compte de
quelque chose il n'a peut-être peut-être
la peur de sa vie et s'est dit peut-être
que là je suis passé à côté de quelque
chose ou alors je disais aussi avait il
a peut-être eu la pression de sa femme
qui lui a dit qu'il a posé un ultimatum
mais bon à ce niveau là je passe passe
on est sportif de haut niveau
mais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas s'il a eu
comme un des gros samarie sur l'assaut
sa dernière sortie
bah il a peut-être pris conscience de
quelque chose et il sait dribbler le
sport c'est bien mais mais il ya des
choses plus importantes dans la vie
notamment ses enfants et sa femme et sa
famille n'est pas houle un vendée globe
ça se prépare généralement en quatre ans
il ya plusieurs petites courses
entre-temps route du rhum transat
jacques vabre l'est ça faisait quatre
ans qui préparait le projet au bout de
deux semaines
il abandonne forcément ça met un coup
derrière la tête et ça ne donne pas
forcément envie de repartir sur un
projet de quatre ans ben ça décourage
forcément d'autant plus qu'il ya
derrière aussi des gros organisation des
fonds qui sont mobilisés et c'est donc
c'est à chaque fois c'est un gros chemin
de croix donc
moi je peux tout à fait comprendre
combien le mansois essoufflé et que
c'est quelque chose qu'on n'ait plus
envie de le refaire
quatre ans c'est long du coup d'envoi
sur pour à chaque fois préparé cet
événement là ils pensaient nuit et jour
et se focaliser dessus donc non pour moi
c'est c'est déjà trop à 39 ans c'est
déjà beaucoup je pense beaucoup trop
pour vous alors le projet initiative
coeur ne va pas mourir pour autant
tanguy de lamotte va continuer à
soutenir l'association et c'est la
navigatrice britannique samantha davies
qui va le remplacer
la sportive de 42 ans aura pour mission
de collecter de l'argent à travers le
projet sportif
objectif sauver les enfants avec des
problèmes cardiaques comme tanguy de
lamotte
on écoute justement temps il a motyl
nous parle de samantha davies comme moi
la fille ni un vendée globe est elle
abandonnée un deuxième vendée globe elle
a monté un projet donc ça c'est très
important de savoir ce que ça représente
d'avoir la chance d'avoir mon sort elle
est très à l'aise sur un bateau et voilà
c'est vrai que c'est c'est moi c'est la
personne à laquelle je voulais
transmettre ce projet si je si j'ai
envisagé de partir alors on sent
vraiment dans le discours tant il est
morte une volonté de passer le flambeau
c'est aussi positif africain anderson
que ça se passe dans les meilleures
conditions
finalement oui parce qu'on avait un peu
voilà tanguy la désigne comme héritière
vieux du projet initiative coeur n'en
avait déjà discuté et c'est vrai que au
delà de l'aspect sportif ya l'aspect
humain et c'est vrai qu'au final il
faisait peut-être de la voile aussi pour
aider les enfants et que final la voile
c'était plus simple un médium un moyen
d'atteindre un plus grand objectif qui
dépasse de loin le cadre du sport parce
qu a pas grand chose qui peut qui peut
rivaliser avec aider des enfants malades
et essayer de lever des fonds justement
et peut-être que qu'il a trouvé dans la
demoiselle une personne capable de faire
aussi bien voire mieux que lui et dans
ce cas là c'est tout à fait tout à fait
raisonnable de lui confier les clés du
bateau
jean-mi c'est la bonne personne a déjà
réussi à boucler un vendée globe en 2008
2009 en 95 jours
finalement elle peut faire aussi aussi
bien que tanguy de lamotte qui avait
déjà
donc les un vendée globe lui aussi
aucune raison et puis je pense que toute
façon il le projet pour le mener pour le
mener à bien il n'a pas choisi n'importe
qui et là aussi on en parlait tout à
l'heure mais c'est peut-être la preuve
qu'ils manquent de motivation pour ce
projet là et que dès le début puisque
ladite deux semaines donc c'est dès le
début voilà il se dit non je préfère
arrêter de suite et puis laisser des
marais quelqu'un parce que deux semaines
et c'est un du tout donc c'est comme
s'ils savaient pas démarré et il sait
peut-être pas senti elle n'a pas senti
la motivation nécessaire pour aller au
bout comme comment lundi sur le plateau
ccva 39 ans à la fois à la fois jeune
mais c'est pas la fois trop trop jeune
et elle a repris le flambeau en étant
peut-être doublement motivés et le fait
que ce soit une femme hélène ça peut
aussi jouer sur initiative coeur vu que
c'est une femme il n'y a pas beaucoup de
monde de la voile
il y aura sûrement un petit coup
marketing on peut on peut le dire avec
cette venue c'est sûr que jouer c'est
sûr qu'elle va être suivi aucune femme
sur le vendée globe le vendée globe
elle va être très très suivie mais non
elle déjà elle va être suivi parce que
elle prend sa suite déjà et elle a
étudié oui parce que c'est une femme et
que on va attendre ses résultats et voir
ce que ça va donner
on va la suivre en tout cas on passe
maintenant notre deuxième focus du jour
il concerne les jeux olympiques pour
soutenir la candidature de paris aux jo
de 2024 le cio et donnera sa décision le
13 septembre prochain à lima au pérou
mais pour faire pencher à la balance du
côté de la candidature parisienne
quelques coups de pédales ont été donnée
ce mercredi au vélodrome nationale parmi
les personnalités présentes on pouvait
apercevoir le staff et les cyclistes de
l'équipe de france le président de la
ffc michel callot et le président de
saint quentin en yvelines michel logis
l'homme politique était justement au
micro de tv fil 78
on veut les jeux dans ce vélodrome donc
la meilleure des choses c'est de prouver
par la participation que les choses ne
peuvent se faire voilà donc même moi qui
ne suis pas cyclistes j'ai souhaité être
aussi sur vélo pour faire voir notre
détermination pour avoir les jeux à 50
heures de jeu
j'en lis les hommes politiques qui
mouillent leur chemise pour les jo c'est
ce que vous en pensez
en ce moment c'est d'actualité sur les
hommes politiques on n'entend parler que
le solde début de l'année dans sa
logique qui soutient quand même la
candidature depuis j'ai depuis le début
des jeux olympiques je crois que tout le
monde tout le monde est derrière cette
candidature tellement il ya tellement
longtemps qu'on les a pas eues mais là
c'est vrai que là 2024 2028 ce sera pas
là ce sera donc on va dire paris en 2024
et los angeles en 2028 quoi comme ça ils
ont le temps de trop près justement
finalement ses coups de pédales sur la
piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pourrait être
inutile à part pour le cardio de michel
laugier
sauf coup de théâtre le sait ou devrait
décider mi-juillet d'annoncé non pas une
mais deux attributions en septembre
prochain au pérou
cette décision fait suite à une
recommandation d'une commission qui a
étudié le sujet début juin la question
sur ce thème est ce que ça sera
est-ce que c'est la bonne décision de la
part du cio est-ce que ça serait la
bonne décision de la part du seuil ou
7,12 attributions de faire une double
attribution finalement lieu d'une
non enfin petit duel entre raul et
genlis genlis ont commencé oui je sais
pas pourquoi j'ai dit non mais un débat
allez-y faites le débat aura double
attribution
ça enlève un petit peu le charme en
moins en moins de sens s'il peut y en
avoir à travers les candidatures parce
que là ça veut dire que c'est bloqué
jusqu'en 2028 quoi dire que les deux
candidats on a dit mais il ya deux
candidats
et puis b pour vexer personne ou pour
laisser toutes les installations qui ont
commencé à être prévue à droite et à
gauche on ebay vous l'aurez en une 24e
puis vous le rendez vous devez tout
c'est la consolante donc sa vis-à-vis
des autres pays candidats
je trouve que c'est un petit peu c'est
un petit peu léger pour moi voilà tout
simplement parce que les deux camps des
deux candidats un pisteur bombe a plus
ou moins les récompenser quoi donc voilà
pourquoi ce titre là je dis non
raul moi je suis assez favorable parce
que j'ai toujours été sensible au fait
quand on forcément quand on contourne
est en concurrence pour préparer un
événement d'une envergure comme les jo
on mobilise énormément de choses et puis
quand on quand on n'a pas cette
attribution on a vraiment l'impression
que toute cette énergie a été mobilisée
pour rien et moi je trouve ça super
triste vraiment très dramatique
donc finalement le le tout ce travail là
bas mais du coup il est pas il n'est pas
fait pour rien on a au contraire on a la
chance de pouvoir bénéficier plus de
temps et finalement les yeux on est en
concurrence pour une date mais après
c'est pas le concours celui qui va faire
les plus beaux joyaux alors qu'une ville
fait n'est finalement bénéficie de plus
de temps pour offrir des deux plus
belles images et des plus grands
spectacles au monde entier bah bon bah
je trouve ça je trouve ça que positive
donc c'est pour ça que tu favorable à sa
voix la fabrique
je prends un peu mieux figue mi raisin
je trouve que c'est un peu dommage parce
que ce moment et peut-être d'autres
d'autres candidatures qui se préparait
pour 2028 du travail qui a été fait en
amont étaient parmi ceux qui sont
désistés aussi il attendait peut-être si
on dit peut-être 2024 peut-être que
l'essai au nez ne l'est pas annoncés
avant finalement non mais peut-être
peut-être qu'au final on n'aura pas
forcément la meilleure candidature
possible en 2028 peut-être qu'il y avait
d'autres dossiers corée entre temps de
crise car entre temps devenu meilleur
peut-être qu'il y avait d'autres offres
auraient été plus intéressante pour
l'autre
c'est vrai que ça aurait d'autres
candidatures oui et puis ça fait ça fait
surtout ça fait la plata ça montre
vraiment que les jeux olympiques c'est
quand même un enjeu financier et
politique assez important et que c'est
pas c'est pas l'aspect sportif qui a
dicté de l'attribution des jeux c'est
plus c'est plus le projet la logistique
est derrière donc c'est pas plus mal
parce que c est plus de temps pour
s'organiser mais est-ce qu'on aurait vu
le bébé paraissent que celui de 2028 de
mérite vraiment d'avoir le 2028
ça laisse pas la question en suspens de
l'autre côté hélène ça permet de faire
des économies aussi de faire cette
double attribution finalement oui oui
assayas h aucun dossier de candidature
c'est plusieurs millions d'euros de
l'énergie investie comme le disait raul
a précédemment cct chômage est aussi des
vins je veux dire on va parler politique
mais je veux pas de couper non non la
saisie c'est vrai quand on voit le
nombre de choses qui a réglé en suivant
plus dans un pays et qu'on mobilise des
fonds pour quelque chose qui finalement
n'a pas lieu
on s'est un peu fort mais je suis tout à
fait d'accord et pour faire passer la
pilule justement jean miss le sait ou
devrait verser 2 milliards avant 2024
pour aider au développement du sport en
californie par exemple si c'est le seul
geste qui est choisi pour 2028 c'est
bien fait favorable et pourquoi pas ben
oui vos membres et paris doit avoir les
jo de 2024 ou 2028 selon vous un fabec
regardez 2024 ça faisait cent ans
exactement que depuis les derniers jo
donc pour le symbole c'était pas mal oui
aussi après après ce qu'est ce qui est
un peu dommage c'est que on se retrouve
avec eux la france et les états unis qui
vont être récompensés c'est pas
forcément les pays qu'on a besoin de
ressources pour développer le sport
brésil a sûrement plus bénéficier des
jets au niveau développement sportif que
non que ne peut en bénéficier les états
unis par exemple quand on voit comment
ces structures et tout le monde fait
déjà du sport est à nouveau centre
industries du sport déjà là-bas en place
il n'y aura pas le plus grave
je pense pas que ça rapportera autant au
pays organisateur que si ça avait été un
un pays en voie de développement il ya
déjà des peut-être d'autres candidatures
qui aurait pu être plus intéressante je
sais pas où il y avait budapest qui
était écrite en course peut être qu'en
hongrie ça aurait été plus plus
bénéfique pour landry de pour son
secteur de l'industrie du sport
d'organiser les jeux olympiques peut
être qu'il y avait c'est dans ce sens là
où j'étais un peu déçu peut vaincre que
je suis un peu déçu que les deux
arrivent d'un coup parce que les deux
les 2 les deux finalistes finalement
sont déjà sept ans et c'est déjà des
riches s'est passé pas des pays qui ont
besoin des joues pour développer leur
sport ils ont déjà tout ce qu'il faut à
côté alors que d'autres pays qui
pourraient en tirer peut-être plus de
profits hélène le sait ou devrait
attribuer à chaque fois deux
candidatures à chaque chaque élection
voilà ça permettrait peut-être à
certains pays de devoir venir d'avoir le
temps de construire ça a été voilà comme
on a pu le voir au brésil c'était un
petit peu short un peu court au niveau 2
de tout ce qui est infrastructure ils
ont mis du temps à construire ça a été
fait même au dernier moment dans
certains cas est-ce que ça permettrait à
certains pays en développement justement
d'avoir le temps d'avoir 8 ans 9 ans 10
ans pour se préparer
oui de toute façon je pense que chaque
fin les pays ont pas les mêmes moyens ni
les mêmes les mêmes moyens financiers
les mêmes moyens logistiques aussi de
ballades créer des infrastructures pour
les jo ça leur permet de voir venir de
financer tout ça de le savoir vraiment
un avant ça permet de faire que j'ai ou
se passe mieux accueille mieux et puis
bon il ya les pays qui ont vraiment
besoin de plus de temps
donc oui après je sais plus qui les
hissa je préférais où ça gâche un petit
peu le bal charme de le dire vraiment
dix ans avant quoi je vois là je trouve
que away vraiment trop tôt
je trouve que c'est c'est une date à la
fois je préfère une interphone alors ce
ne sera pas tout à fait une première
est-ce que vous en avez est-ce que vous
avez une idée raul par exemple des
double attribution scan a déjà eu dans
l'histoire selon vous je n'ai pas eu
connaissance
pas du tout connaissance alors il ya
cent ans pour les jeux olympiques de
1924 et de 1928 le baron pierre de
coubertin avait demandé aussi aux en
1921 attribué les jo en 2000 en 1924 à
paris sa ville natale pour fêter sa
retraite en 1925 une sorte de cadeau
pour schématiser mais le jour même
amsterdam candidate pour les jo de 1924
s'est finalement vu attribuer du coup
les jo de 1928 donc ça c'était déjà très
bien terminé pour pour paris jean
missiles réaction pendant cette petite
histoire
mais voilà non mais c'est celle du buzz
c'est un petit peu ce qu'on dit autour
la table passé derrière c'est l'école
des fans
il ya pas de berne area près de perdre à
ya pas de vainqueur vous l'aurez 24 et
l'autre 28 comme ça personne ne pleure
et tout le monde est content et tous les
efforts qui ont été mobilisés pour la
préparation de ces événements pourront
continuer et
dans ce sens là qu'on voit la cache a
sonné on passe maintenant notre rubrique
débats
alors notre débat sera axée aujourd'hui
sur le à chênée open de france de golf
qui se déroulera du 29 juin au dimanche
2 juillet sur les greens du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines le
tournoi devait passer cette année dans
une nouvelle dimension avec son
intégration au rolex séries et à
l'augmentation de sa dotation à près de
6 6 millions d'euros mais cette année
contrairement à 2016 il n'y aura pas de
noms ronflants comme le nord-irlandais
rory mcilroy
mais le public pourra quand même voir un
action john rame numéro 10 mondial alex
north end le suédois nonuple vainqueur
sur le tour européen à 34 ans il y aura
aussi graeme mcdowell martin gamer et
tomasz pieters le belge dans les têtes
d'affiché des grands joueurs donc mais
pas d'immenses stars planétaires la
raison le tournoi est passé entre l'us
open et l'open britannique deux des plus
gros tournois de la saison est aussi
juste avant le irish open du 6 au 9
juillet et certains joueurs ont préféré
faire l'impasse sur le rendez-vous
france est une déception qui pourrait
pousser les organisateurs à décaler la
date de l'open de france nous avons posé
la question au dtn à christophe muniesa
la date est bonne excellente et il n'est
pas question à court terme moyen terme
de la modifier
mais évidemment ce que vous soulignez
parfaitement exact les joueurs notamment
les joueurs du top niveau mondial qui
sont extrêmement sollicités tant par le
ciel que le circuit américain font des
arbitrages
donc on peut se targuer d'avoir un très
bon plateau mais pour franchir une étape
supplémentaire
il faudrait rentrer dans le calendrier
des quatre épreuves du grand chelem ce
qui est statutairement impossible une
autre alternative serait de compter dans
les épreuves de championnat du monde et
ça peut être un objectif à moyen terme
pour l'open de la question sur ce thème
l'open de france va-t-il à changer ses
dates pour grandir oui ou non vous
mettez oui ou non
les partager ouais mais partagée même
chose raul
non pourquoi banon ne suis pas je suis
pas forcément pour la solution de
facilité je me dis que dans ces cas là
il faut essayer de redonner un peu plus
d'envergure à l'événement soit la
dotation soit l'organisation
soissons est extrêmement élevé cette
année justement 6,6 millions d'euros
c'est trois fois plus à peu marre et que
l'année dernière alors oui ou de te
retrouver des trouver les ingrédients
qui font que le que le
l'événement suscite un challenge
supérieure pour ça que j'aime bien le
discours du dtn se être confiant sa date
dans son organisation mais aller
chercher d'autres d'autres solutions
pour que le le tournoi bénéficie de
nouveaux d'un plateau haut de gamme même
si c'est déjà un peu le cas apparemment
a quand même c'est le cas en voilà
oui je pense que les nouveaux enfin les
nouveaux les compétitions je ne sais pas
comment on appelle ça mais les nouveaux
championnat de golf deviennent de plus
en plus gros et plus en plus connue avec
le temps après c'est aux grands joueurs
aussi de ba de faire le choix de tel ou
tel championnat cette année ils ont
favorisé voilà les championnats habituel
ça sort des thons ou résumées élèves du
coup il ya 150 tournois majeurs mais les
grands joueurs ne jouent finalement que
22 25 tournois par an donc forcément il
faut faire un choix comme vous disiez et
puis en même temps si on change la date
y en aura il y aura un autre championnat
pas très loin
je sais pas s'il ya réellement une date
idéale question à moi c'est ce que dans
le bas dans le classement mondial
du golfe ou dans les points d'une ligue
ou autre
est-ce que ce championnat a les mêmes
même coefficient que les rolex séries
voilà finalement partis qui font
finalement partie des plus gros tournois
donc maintenant européen il fait déjà
partie du grand chelem du golf pas les
grands chelems juste à catégorie dance
ou l'équivalent un peu d des masters
1000 c'est déjà bien pour la france qui
est pas forcément à payer deux golfeurs
munitions pour moi le la en france on
pratique surtout le golf par hobby on a
aussi beaucoup de golfeurs dans une
certaine catégorie de genre on remarque
par rapport aux pays anglophones je
pense que on peut retrouver des golfeurs
chez tout le monde
que la france se positionne déjà en
sueur sur des tournois de second plan
c'est déjà bien et ça voudrait dire ça
serait peut-être un aveu de faiblesse
finalement déplacé la date jean miss
celui bien finalement voilà on déplace
la date parce que notre tournoi n'est
pas assez prestigieux pour être à cette
date là mais oui tout à fait moi je dis
qu'il faut il faut pas céder
mais simplement il faut il faut remettre
notre tournoi tour de l'open de france a
à sa juste valeur dont l'a dit on l'a
dit il a juste avant c'est que il ya des
ddd des tonneaux à l'open de l'us open
et puis l'autre c'est lequel l'autre qui
sont british open
c'est beau mais ce sont les riches open
est un tournoi et finalement du même
niveau que l'open de france qui arrive à
tirer
rory mcilroy mais bon alors c'est un
arrière central et réduit la misère
qu'il faut connaître les raisons pour
lesquelles aussi ces tournois nature est
ce que le prix est ce que les prix sont
beaucoup plus élevés ou est ce que c'est
les à-peu-près déjà nombre équivalent
alors à peu près équivalent sais c'est
bizarre que raul a peut-être raison
c'est peut-être le côté le côté côté
convivialité en irlande qui fait que je
voilà la ryder cup aux états unis mais
j'allais voir vous étiez déplacer
michael moyenne question d'ambiance je
pense de choix et c'est peut-être qu'ils
qui attire plus les golfeurs dans ce
panel britannique où il fait voilà qui
serait peut-être plus la recherche je
suis à la mosler un petit peu plus
propre au sport mais finalement frédéric
voilà il n'y a pas vraiment de surprise
parce que là l'augmentation de la
dotation allez allez réel mais
finalement ce tournoi a toujours attiré
de bons joueurs il ya eu ballestero qui
a été quatre fois vainqueur de l'épreuve
entre les années 70 et 80 il ya eu
thomas levet que tu ne connais ici en
france voilà qui est une pointure
mondiale on peut le dire en france mais
il n'y a pas eu des pointures mondiales
de du timing d'un tiger woods par
exemple la leçon à son meilleur niveau
la taille quand vous ce n'est pas très
joli à l'open de france de golf ça
dépend aussi de l'ambition des
organisateurs peut-être qu'ils veulent
monter un tournoi majeur semble pour vos
fins sans vouloir nécessairement
rivaliser que des trophées du grand
chelem parce que je pense que comme
s'ils ont choisi la date ils ont bien vu
comment était organisé les différentes
compétitions
ils ont bien vu par rapport à la date
qu'ils allaient pas rivaliser avec le
british open donc je pense que ça doit
être cohérent avec leurs ambitions on
peut faire un très bon c'est comme s'il
y avait un tournoi tennis qui se monte
entre entre roland gaben la période
entre roland garros et wimbledon et qui
veut devenir aussi grand que roland
garros et wimbledon
ça n'arrivera pas c'est pas possible
d'arriver d'arrivée tout de suite dans
la cour des grands sans rien faire donc
je pense que non je pense que je pense
que c'est ils ont pas changé la date
c'est si ça reste dans l'optique de
continuer à se développer et devenir un
événement incontournable et 6 il ya du
jeu de qualité et s'il ya de la
compétition
je pense que les grands joueurs sont
naturellement à attirer sur sur des
compétitions équivalente par exemple y
aura peut-être plus de joueurs si l'open
de france il est intéressant que
viendront en france plutôt qu'aller en
iran
ça c'est ça c'est envisageable par
contre d'espérer que les gars préfère
aller en france plutôt qu'aller au
british open ces bonis croyez pas c'est
pas la même tradition et le golf c'est
un sport de tradition pour pouvoir
changer le statu quo dans ces conditions
là c'est pas c'est pas choisir le plus
facile des défis vous parler tennis
justement tout à l'heure pour les
changements de calendrier il ya
l'exemple du masters 1000 de madrid qui
a changé de dimension en 2009
le tournant a été replacé en mai à leurs
qualités au mois d'avril pour devenir un
tournoi de préparation vue de roland
garros
et là on a pu voir des djokovic des
nadal et federer sur la terre battue
madrilène finalement
le changement de date a été bénéfique
finalement fait d'accord mais ressort
peut-être que là aussi il ya pis y'a
plus de temps entre l'open d'australie
et un roland garros
ce qui fait qu en rapprochant madrid de
roland garros ou plus ça devait être la
même surface la terre battue c'est
devenu la terre battue avec avec
justement ce changement avantage ou en
intérieur en dur donc eux ça leur a
permis de ça leur a permis de développer
le tournoi dans le cadre d'un cahier
justement de l'équipe de l'open de
france où il n'ya pas de singularité
plus que ça entre deux points c'est
entre deux grosses dates en fait c'est
ça le peut-être le souci que y'avait pas
avec madrid malgré cet été était pile à
mi chemin ils sont rendus compte que
peut-être six rapprocher d'une confiance
sur et plus d'intérêt de mon tournoi
la déplacer la date de l'open de france
je suis pas sûr que ça ramène beaucoup
plus de monde
à moins de faire vraiment une autre
période de l'année quoi il peut y avoir
un effet à ryder cup peut-être hélène ce
sera la guerre la question de cette
émission est est ce qui aura un effet
ryder cup la coupe du monde du coup du
golfe qui s'implantera à 51 ans et demi
sur les communes de saint quentin en
yvelines en 2018 en septembre 2018 est
ce qu'il peut y avoir un effet après que
les joueurs se disent finalement le
parcours est bien il ya une bonne
ambiance on peut rendre pour reviendra à
l'avenir à l'open de france
oui après de toute façon je pense que
sas teste ça se fait les si les gens ont
envie de revenir y reviendrons on est je
sais pas depuis combien de temps l'open
de france fait
féfé championnat tous les ans tous les
ans mais depuis combien de temps c'est
peut-être un championnat assez jeune et
qui nécessite les 90 kg né qui jouait
auparavant dans d'autres golfs parisien
était très connue terrain si le terrain
est bien si peut-être que ça peut
motiver des joueurs à venir
et voilà et qu'ils aient un effet de
masse peut-être il ya une autre chose
avec le
le golf le golf vous en parler du tennis
tout à l'heure vous assurer que pour
faire plusieurs tournois
physiquement on peut comprendre que
sportif peut pas pas
comme ça inquiets les tournois les uns
derrière les autres mais au golf quand
même même effort physique
donc il pourrait violer faire tout cela
et les droits les trois 3 open il est
faux ainsi si les golfeurs vous entendre
en tout cas j'en lis et oui j'espère
qu'ils viendront à l'open de france de
golf l'année prochaine données et venez
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve le jeudi
6 juillet pour un nouveau numéro de six
ans par les sports à bientôt sur
téléphiles 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]